now vladimir putin has responded to
opposition to the war in his own country
with increasing repression new laws
threatened 15 years in jail for sharing
so-called misinformation thousands of
people have been detained for protesting
now alexa navalny is the kremlin's most
prominent critic he's on jail
and now his spokesperson has also been
placed on a most wanted list as well now
to get a sense of just how harsh the
crackdown is in russia and and you hope
there may be of an uprising against
putin i spoke to alexander valni's chief
of staff leonard volkov who is in
lithuania this is what he had to tell me
thank you so much for coming on the
program today
we've all seen the horrors coming out of
ukraine children killed as they've been
trying to flee maternity hospitals
being bombed
how have you felt watching that
it feels enormously painful
it feels
i mean
i want to cry
like putin is president of russia this
is putin's four this is not my war i'm
trying to cry as loud as possible and i
ask my fellow compatriots to cry this is
not our war not in our name he's doing
it not in our name but
it looks like so far we are not strong
enough to stop him and he is continuing
to do all these enormous
things and crimes and war crimes in our
name and we can't stop thinking about
how it will define
future of our country
in the 21st century what will people
think and
tell of us like in 10 or 20 years will
russia become
the nazi germany of the 21st century
that's actually the questions that could
impose us and we urge all our
competitors like to do whatever possible
to stop him before it's too late you
talk about the russian people perhaps
not being strong enough to stop
what's happening
and of course there have been russians
who have been protesting against the war
in ukraine but some in the west might
think why haven't more people being
taken to the streets to try and overflow
vladimir putin what would you say to
that
when when i hear this question i say oh
sorry guys you and the west still don't
understand a thing
uh this is this is big problem like the
west was trying to to comprehend like
putin putin's russian and what's going
on and still many people do not
understand what that what's actually
going on so in russia now
just turning out for a peaceful protest
rally against war you would face up to
15 years imprisonment and still there
are people that participate in this
produce like every day and every weekend
and we've seen massive protests uh on
sunday march 6 and we have called for
another rallies and we'll see in other
realities this sunday
this despite enormous risks these people
are taking and
last sunday
over 5000 people have been detained
which means that over like 50 000 people
at least have turned out this despite
this enormous harassment and risk and uh
persecution they are facing like 50 000
people brave enough to say okay i cannot
accept all this horror being done like
in my name so i'm ready to go to jail
for 15 years just just because this is
so unbearable
everyone who protests now in russia is
enormously brave and everyone who who
protests represents
thousands other people who stay at home
who are not brave enough to turn out but
they are not to be blamed putin has
built an authoritarian regime for 20
years a regime where like public
expression of descent has been made
barely possible i think you're right
when you say that people in the west
perhaps just don't understand the
situation and i think there has been
perhaps a misunderstanding of who putin
is it can be quite difficult for us to
really predict what he's going to do
because he is such a different leader to
the ones we're used to if the war isn't
going as planned as many think how do
you think he's going to react to someone
who's seen putin operate over many years
well first of all here i have to admit
we also didn't get put in right so we
the russian opposition we have been
fighting with him for years we have
considered him to be evil like poisoning
our friends with novichok and arresting
us in harass so i've spent like
four months under arrest and many uh
many of my friends much more and so on
but we always have considered him racial
evil vibrational
now with this war it's clear it's clear
that we were wrong because these were
first of all things doesn't make any
sense he already destroyed russian
economy he already destroyed russian
army he already destroyed russian future
like there is i mean the the future of
our country is now like very very
unclear what it will be like the diparia
in the world like for many years now
so
no rational man would do it and we have
considered him to be rational so now we
have to reassess it and we have to
consider him to be like a crazy person
which apparently he is now it's so com
it's so challenging to to predict what a
crazy person would do next we try more
to address like people around him who
cannot be crazy like all of them and of
course our letter actions
the protest and uh
working on sanctions list and talking to
like western leaders on this sanction
list are all to install as many cracks
as possible in in the in putin's inner
circle people around him like a palace
coupe
like a revolution someone of his close
co-workers turning against him is pretty
much the only chance now to stop this
war
uh what would putin do if
not everything goes according to his
plan well everything already doesn't go
up according to his plan he was clearly
playing a blitzkrieg he was about to
take
keith in maybe four or five days
when he is now calling for uh people to
come from syria to join russian army
forces it's a very clear sign that not
everything went according to his plan of
course no initial plan could include
importing like syrians uh syrian
warriors like to protect the the russian
christian of world so but now a lot of
things of course depend uh depending on
the people of ukraine of how they are
ready to fight and they're doing it very
good on people of russia how they're
ready to fight and we are calling for
protests and people turn and participate
in this protest and of course of the
world like it's now very clear that
enormous cost has to be paid to stop
this for
this all the sanctions of course
they also uh
create a burden on the european economy
that that's quite clear but this cost
has to be paid because otherwise putin
will just
destroy the world you say he could
destroy the world do you think he would
be prepared to
use nuclear weapons that's clearly what
many leaders around the world are
concerned about
as he is crazy enough
we cannot we can expect unfortunately
everything
uh
clearly not winning the war against
ukraine and he might think about other
solutions more powerful weapons more
powerful
solutions to to to change the course of
this war which is now not so successful
for him
and just finally um in your answer
earlier you said that the one chance of
ending this would be for those around
putin to try and stop him
do you think that could happen the
kremlin do you think if there do you
think there are enough cracks in those
around him in his inner circle to stop
this war and to perhaps even depose him
yeah i think so i think i mean this is
probably the the only chance but it is
quite feasible
because
his elite is clearly unhappy with what
is going on and many oligarchs have
already publicly spoken out against
putin's war
which is quite unheard of and many of
people around him are of course also not
like bloody
maniacs and do not want
this all to happen
so i believe that rationally
it could happen that some some of people
in his inner circle will decide that
okay they are ready to take the risk but
to stop it and they will know that well
the world will be thankful also for them
i can't call any names i can't say this
guy will
will probably try to
create uh such a revolutionary situation
this is not predictable but
we have to keep trying keep working to
create more pressure on these people
around footing to make this scenario
more probable and thank you so much for
your insights it's been really
fascinating to talk so thank you